I think that's probably most frustrating
is is we knew that that was gonna happen
at some point at some point you're not
gonna be able to run the ball for 180
yards even with the best running back in
the NFL and that's when you have to be
able to throw the ball you have to be
able to make plays you have to be able
to you know hit the ball at the deep
balls you have to do that because
otherwise it's too easy for teams tee up
and rush the quarterback so we have to
be we have to be able to run the ball
and pass the ball out of feel on the
Vikings receiver after Sunday's game and
that in context with other things he
said there was a moment he was wide open
and he said you know the play went well
the ball just didn't get there it became
very obvious even though he said it with
a kind of a flat straight demeanor then
he was throwing his quarterback under
the bus a little bit and he should he
should because it's not acceptable
twenty-eight million a year on a
three-year fully guaranteed contract
they've now had 20 games with Kirk
Cousins there are 28 left under this
contract I don't know what they're gonna
do after the next 12 that they play when
they don't make it to the playoffs this
year because when I see games like
yesterday and two weeks ago Green Bay
when they could have won the game and
Kirk Cousins throws the ball into double
coverage inexplicably at the quarterback
is the weakness of the offense the
highest-paid player on the team is the
weakness of the offense okay I mean
listen it's not great I'm not gonna say
he's the weakness of the offense well
okay I'll get to it alright but you know
yes to your point when you pay a
quarterback 28 million dollars I'm not
gonna disagree with you that I'd like to
see a little more here and there like
hey guys we're not playing good get on
my back and I'll make a few plays and
get us back on track doesn't have that G
doesn't do I mean maybe he doesn't like
I'm not gonna disagree with you I don't
know I also will say this though to
defend him I will you know me I like to
watch film and do all that crap i watch
them in a Soto offense and their past
schemes and go it's about as
underwhelming as it gets in the NFL why
this is my biggest it's just simple as
can be I mean they're running plays that
New England would be like but we
practices as our rookies and and guys
are getting open it doesn't matter yes
well he missed a few but it's very hard
sometimes and you don't get to get in a
rhythm and get like easy completions and
things like that and then you're trying
to stay dedicated to the run game and
they've been a run team here through the
first you know four weeks of this
season two where I don't think they've
really done anything to gonna get the
past game going to this point go through
more than 30 passes in Green Bay and it
didn't work out he threw more than 30
passes yesterday 36 to be exact right it
didn't work out they couldn't get
anything going in the first half they
had two drives in the first half at 59
total yards in the first half yeah
that's great because mm-hmm we're
getting ready you know it's hard to
process what's going on the four o'clock
games because we're trying to get ready
to do a TV show right right but right
after halftime Tracy Wilson of CBS
saying I spoke to Mike Zimmer before the
start of the third quarter and he said
even though they're having difficulty
running the ball they're going to
continue to run the ball they know they
need to run the ball they're gonna run
the ball cut to the action Kirk Cousins
drops back to pass strip sack from
Khalil my first playable right yeah so
III don't know whether it's a play
calling thing I don't know I look but
it's just not working and to have Adam
Thielen publicly say what you and I both
know privately has been ricocheting
around that locker room yeah as it
relates to Kirk Cousins ability to step
up in big moments and that's
fundamentally the problem Chris and you
played quarterback you know guys either
can do this so they can you either in a
moment where it's a big game a big play
a big drive you either respond or you
get so freaked out by because you're so
aware of it right everybody else
eventually gets freaked out to the
remember it's Super Bowl 23 the story
about Joe Montana yeah John Kennedy
relaxed every juror right Kirk Cousins I
think gets so keyed up in those moments
and now it's spilling over to everyone
else after 20 games yeah of it and and
it's falling apart it's look I felt
after they beat the Raiders by 20 points
maybe they're on to something right but
if they can't run they definitely can't
throw they like that one-dimensional
high school team that everybody knows is
in their town they're like hey they run
the ball around the ball over on the
ball and everything's great until they
come up against the team that stops them
they can't do it well yeah that's that's
the issue and that was the question I
think going into the game is that they
can't run the ball what are they gonna
do with this pass offense it's something
I've written down in my notes a lot like
okay if they can't do this are they
gonna be able to rely we haven't had a
Kirk Cousins you like that moment right
with the Minnesota Vikings so I get it I
understand and I can understand the
locker room leg going like you know is
this guy gonna pull us through in big
moments because you certainly didn't get
the confidence with the stupid
interception in Green Bay
and then yesterday and you know again I
wasn't ever as good as Kirk Cousins or
some of the other guys in the NFL but my
one season of glory when we went to the
playoffs and everything like that
we did have some comeback wins where I
felt like the team believed in me after
one or two of them and then hey we
didn't win every one of them but I know
that the belief was there that like man
Chris got us through some tough spots
and made some big plays he's capable of
doing that and I don't think he's kind
of instilled that confidence in that
offense yet we're or you I mean you wore
purple here today I don't know for a
phone they hung in the clock it is too
much of true Biscay the shoulder in the
game lining up for the Vikings Hakeem
Hicks is out wrote Quan Smith is a
Mitchell true Biscay gets injured chase
Daniel knows that offense and and they
may be with that defense they may be
better off with a guy who knows the
offense who runs the offense who doesn't
try to do too much because true Biscay
store work he really is I mean he is I
know Matt Negi tells some people behind
the scenes that he can't install his
full offense which er Biscay and that's
that he he you know and I think that's
the advantage chase Daniel brings a
chased in did well yesterday and maybe
I'm mad about that laughs well it
bothers me yeah right
it's not a great way to start off okay
but you don't start off you're a
relationship like that will be back
[Music]
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports